Hey, how's it going bros, my name is PewDiePie!
Just wanted to make a quick video to say thanks. I know it's a bit redundant ... ahh okay.
But I realized that I never really got a chance to fully express my gratitude,
For... all the support that I've gotten throughout these past couple days
I don't think I've gotten this much support... EVER
Of- of me making videos, these past six years on Youtube.
And, it really turned this shitty situation completely around,
And all the support that I've been getting from you guys has just been incredible!
It seemed that people that doesn't even necessarily consume my content came to support me,
Throughout this whole thing with the media because they thought the whole situation was unjustified.
If theres uh, any newcomers.. Aha! Ahh.. uhh..
Domo Arigato!
Thank you very much! [laughs]
Why- Why am I awkward in- in..?
I also didn't realize how much it would mean to me,
The fact that so many people supported me,
because I-I didn't think I'd need it.
But when it seems like the whole world is kinda turned against you and- and is after blood,
To have people defending you, uh even when you haven't gotten the chance to defend yourself,
It really means a lot.
It- It's something that, I know I will never forget.
It was- It was almost like the internet had my back
throughout this whole situation and uh, that has just been so.. incredibly cool
'Cause that's really all I care about.
Um, I didn't make my way to where I am thanks to the media,
I didn't get where I am through them.
I- I made my way through the internet and, and through you guys. And thanks to you guys watching me,
And, if you guys are still supporting me, that means everything to me
Like I couldn't care less what the media thinks about me and what they say about me,
And it clearly, all bridges are seemed
almost burnt at this point, [laughs]
But the fact that you guys, had my back,
It means everything.
Um.. It- It's because I- uh, I-... I saw this coming.
I said it in a video earlier this year I think what i said was something like;
2017 is the year it's gonna go bad for me
Alright, I'm just calling it out right now.
Uh- You want you, get out before you can,
Cause PewDiePie is-... He's a bad boy now,
Anti- anti-Semitic! What other labels can we put him-?
Hitler loving!
The media wants to paint me as some sort of villain
So it went a lot faster and a lot harder
than i thought but I knew it was going to happen
because I-I let all guards down
Like I've been so tired of
everything that I say being taken out of context,
Like even before and I- it's
almost like I have to think what I say
now in every single video because
someone else might watch it that isn't
necessarily my audience and they might
take that one part out of it and put it
on a headline and it's just so stupid
but I realized I'm not going to censor
myself for that. I-I should care about
the ones that actually watch my content
and what they think about it an- and I
think if anything that's been more clear
and obvious to me than ever
Obviously I'm not going to see this as some way to kind of provoke or...
...start drama.
I have really, REALLY no intentions in doing that
There's been those so much
with the drama with the media these past couple of months
but it's really not some...
It's not something I thrive on
It's not something that I feel like;
"What can I do next?!"
If- if anything what I realized about
this whole thing is that,
I really, really, really just care about entertaining my audience
Uh, a lot of people have been
saying "Oh, well he lost so much, he lost
his show and all these things", but
all these things are possible and if
anything now I'm independent for the
first time in four years or five years
and uh I feel great! I feel really really
excited about what opportunities that's going to bring in
and, uhh, if I didn't know better, I would say thank you
to the Wall Street Journal.
Actually, t-thank you, Wall Street Journal! [Laughs]
There's been some real busy couple of days for me and I'm sorry
if the content hasn't really been up to
standard but I feel more committed and
more passionate than- [Burps]
I want to do something bigger about this
whole thing but I-I can't say what it is
but that's for the future but anyway
what I want to say is you guys fucking
rock!
You- you- you, you're fucking awesome! I... I
feel like I don't deserve it, but uh- uh thank you! Thank you very much!
I'm ready to
keep making videos and uh love you!
Also by the way...
JK Rowling is still a Cu-